We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. this is funny.
It's actually kind of good news we've not
heard from previously drunk furious Trump
is Jimmy from Philly for a while, but he is
requesting a name change.
Take a list.
David.
Jimmy from Philly.
Yeah.
From now on, since I've stopped drinking,
I demand you refer to me as the furious psycho
nut Trump supporter instead.
So lager, the drunk Trump supporter because
I'm not drinking anymore.
But a psycho noise would be the a appropriate
term.
Okay.
So Jimmy, I don't know.
I, I'm glad that you're not drinking anymore
because the drinking was becoming a problem
Jimmy was having on some nights that he would
call into the livestreams.
I don't remember if it was four or six of
like a very high alcohol percentage.
A IPA in India, pale ale for the uninitiated,
which by the way, who likes super hoppy beers.
Give me a break, but that's a story for a
different day and I think they were like 11%
so he was having like four to six, which I
believe is like eight to 12 normal beers.
If a normal beer is like 5% I think some of
those like you know, water beers like bud
light or maybe even like two or 3% this guy
was putting down a lot of alcohol.
So I'm glad that you're not drinking.
I think psycho naught might be a reference
to the fact that Jimmy now does LSD.
I don't know if that's a code word for someone
who does LSD, but in any case, Jimmy seems
more lucid when he calls in and for that I
think we can all be grateful.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Democratic Congresswoman Katie Hill is resigning,
uh, because of allegations of improper relationships
with staffers.
We will talk about that.
The police officer who was told to tone down
his gayness, there were not.
Mine has been awarded $19 million in a discrimination
lawsuit and a big gap, a, uh, uh, a chasm
or Chaz him depending on something, uh, has
opened up on the issue of reparations where
75% of African Americans support referee reparations
for slavery, whereas only 15% of white Americans
do according to a new poll.
And we're going to dig in a to a lot of what
is going on with that issue.
On today's bonus show, please get today's
bonus show.
The bonus show is for members and patrons.
You can get instant access@davidpakmandotcomslashmembershiporbybecomingapatronatthefivedollarsamonthorgreaterlevelatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the
David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].